-Finally it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet,"
everyone, her we go.
♪ Weee Tweeeet ♪
♪ We Tweet ♪
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as a group
decide something we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different Tweets,
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
Do you all have voting clickers
at your seats.
I can tell by the mass
confusion.
Uh... You can
vote for all of them
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
And we'll see the results live.
Higgins, Roots, you have
your clickers, too?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-All right, whatever Tweet
gets the most likes,
we will Tweet it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
-Ohhh.
-Yeah.
It's a shared experience. Okay.
That wasn't one of them.
Okay, here we go.
Are you guys ready for this?
The first Tweet is...
"There is little difference
between a hostage situation
and springing a three-hour
board game on someone.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's like, you're stuck playing.
Monopoly.
-Risk.
-Risk!
I forgot the rules of Risk.
That's the word.
-Risk it.
-I played Risk for, like, two
hours and forgot the rules.
-Like, went halfway through, or
just --
-Halfway, like,
maybe 20 minutes in I go,
I don't even know if
that's what the rules --
I forget.
Let's just stop playing.
Yeah, I gotta -- Anyways.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
All right, all right,
you didn't like that one.
That's okay. Wow.
-Wow.
Yeah, audience did not
like that one.
-Did not care for it.
-It's okay.
There's other to choose from.
Here we go.
This next one says...
"I've never seen
someone stressed
while drinking
out of a coconut."
You gotta vote.
-Wow!
You gotta vote for
one of these, guys.
You gotta vote for one of them.
-[ Laughing ]
-Never seen someone stressed...
[ Slurping ] Oh, man.
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
-What about Gilligan?
All right, let's see the results
on this one here.
[ Drum roll ]
No, equally bad. All right.
A little bit better.
-Yeah.
-Little bit better.
-101.
-Yeah. 101.
All right, this next one says...
"The way I handle my food being
passed to my car at a drive-thru
is the same way
I'd handle an infant
being passed to me across
a 10,000-foot ravine.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Be careful.
-Yeah, I got it.
Come on, there's McMuffins
in that thing!
Come on, there's coffee!
There's coffee in there!
-Hey, Ron.
-Uh...
Let's see the results
on this one here.
This one feels --
Oh, there you go!
That's enough!
Now we're talking.
That's -- That could be --
That feels like
it could be something.
Thank you. All right.
That could be something.
Next up, this one says...
Pretty crazy how phones used
to ring and we'd answer them.
[ Laughter ]
Remember that?
-Yeah.
-The phones would ring,
and then you would actually
answer the phone.
-Hello?
-Yeah. Yeah.
Okay, I feel good about this.
Let's see the results on this.
[ Drum roll ]
-Whoa!
-That's what I'm talking about!
Oh, yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Applause ]
I see some fist pumping
happening.
Fist pumping.
-Yeah, up and down.
Fist bumping and pumping.
Throwing -- [ Laughs ]
-Bumping and pumping.
Bumping and pumping, baby.
That was my first album.
-That was your first movie.
Yeah.
-Got taken off the air.
[ Laughter ]
-Bumpin'.
-Bumpin' and pumpin'.
That was your first rap album?
-Yeah.
Yeah, and your last.
-And my last. Yeah.
I liked -- I enjoyed it.
-I know you loved it.
-Oh, yeah.
-No one else did.
-I left it sealed, so...
I knew it was gonna be
worth money.
-I put it up on a shelf
very high.
[ Stammers ]
I put it in the kid's room.
-Did you really? [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-That's uncle Steve.
-[ Laughs ]
-One day that'll be worth
a lot of money.
-'Cause everyone else is gonna
throw them away.
-Yes. That's correct.
All right, so we feel good
about that one?
-Yeah.
-All right, good.
All right. Good.
We like that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. I feel good.
-That might be the winner.
-This last one is...
"I wonder if beard trimmers
get picked up and think,
'I hope we're on
face duty tonight.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Bumpin and pumpin, baby!
-No, no, no! Different thing!
Come on, different thing.
All right, here we go.
You're laughing at it, though.
-I mean, yeah, but no. It's--
- [ Stammers ]
There's nothing you haven't --
-It's a pity laugh.
No, no.
-Hope we're on face duty.
Let's see the results here.
[ Drum roll ]
-Oh, no!
-Whoa, there we go!
The winner is number four!
[ Bell dings ]
"Pretty crazy how phones used
to ring and we'd answer them."
I'm gonna post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed give
it a like, give it a WeTweet,
and enjoy --